là vous à découvrir nos invités dans off
est coté dans sa mort pas il ya beaucoup
de jeunes amis aujourd'hui vous voyez
dans cette année où la situer petit
bisou avec la petite stella qui est venu
nous rejoindre ta taille est notre
invité et puis beaucoup de jeunes
garçons et jeunes filles qui pourront
poser des questions et puis vous aussi
chers amis téléspectateurs vous pourrez
poser des questions aux 26,80 de 20,00
est à taille et se fera un plaisir d'y
répondre du moins je l'espère voilà
bonsoir ça va bien et bien moi ça va
bien en tout cas on est heureux ici de
t'accueillir au milieu de ces jeunes
enfants comme celle approche des
vacances on a voulu aussi
eh bien disons associer nos jeunes amis
à cette émission là j'espère que tu n'y
vois pas d'inconvénient
non je trouve ça super en tout cas ces
gens qu'ils un petit film qui met en
lumière qu'elle vienne s'asseoir à côté
de taille et non elle est un peu timide
et alors elle parlait plus c'est pas
grave alors ta taille et je sais que ça
marche bien pour toi tu as 15 nous fait
entrer il ya nos jeunes amis aussi qui
posons des questions de tout à l'heure
j'espère que tu es prêt à répondre à
toutes les questions
je sais que ça marche bien pour toi tu
fais beaucoup de spectacle beaucoup de
télévision c'est bien si tu fais ton
métier correctement et veniat offert le
jeu de la vérité alors c'est tout ça que
je suis venu ici en préparation pour
t'entraîner le téléphone vous le savez
c'est le 26 82 20 00 et on est tout de
suite en mesure de prendre un premier
rappel voilà
allô allô bonjour bonjour bonjour qui
bonjour taillé un franc comment tu
t'appelles
un beau jour 35 mais s'était rendu
compte récemment à quel âge tu as débuté
oui mais question lâche morrison j'ai
débuté dès que je suis né c'est à dire
quand mon papa m'a construit il ya des
gens d'ici voilà merci francs pour la
question je sais qu'ils sont nombreux
alors on va aller vite pendant les
questions pour que tout le monde puisse
avoir sa chance comme ça on l'a déjà j
-pd
un élan chez chouette c'est pourtant
traîné au jeu de la vérité
on va peut-être tout de suite prendre
une première question avec une jeunes
téléspectatrices qui j'espère est en
place elle va mettre bien son micro et
je crois savoir qu'elle s'appelle du
sida lors tout de suite une première
question avec lui si non alors ça c'est
stella c'est celui ci qui va parler ici
d'une question a vu comment je vous fais
pour parler avec votre ventre c'est un
mois qui m'a sali je ne suis pas juge
jean merckaert est né louis je sais bien
comment il fait il s'est enrichi 155 et
puis par l'ancien mur expliqué peut-être
si tu veux de ventriloque c'est comme
quand on apprend le piano il faut un
petit peu s'entraîner à foire afin
d'avoir un personnage à côté de soi et
puis quand on l'a trouvé le personnage
parce que c'est le plus difficile à
trouver cette attaque était plus dur à
trouver
quand on la trouvait là ce moment là on
essaie de le faire parler comme on fait
parler de marionnettes tu comprends vous
entamez bien tous les deux ouais super à
taez j'ai rien contre 1 ce qui nous
raconte moi on va tout de suite avant de
prendre en main son appel à la levée des
cendres on va la faire descendre après
la petite stella est en train de montrer
sa culotte par la pluie
c'est pas beau tout de suite la question
avec damien l'uci va passer le micro à
notre jeune ami damien qui va poser une
question je t'écoute
est-ce que tu joue bien au football tu
sais que ça c'est une question
d'habitude
parce que rognac je suis tout mou du
côté du dimanche alors je n'arrive pas
tout c'est dans un bal donc j'aimerais
bien mais je suis juste qu'on allait
regarder le mondial à la télévision
c'est tout ce que je sais faire sans
centre et même un temps très dense en
europe n'ont rien à faire là bas avant
d'écouter une première chanson de notre
ami taille et qui bien sûr chanter vous
le savez une question avec sébastien a
atteint
qu'est-ce qui est elle veut descendre à
la ferme et sébastien une question quant
à lui la question moment je parlais avec
la dame est ce que vous aimez bien porte
bien oui ce que j'aime surtout n'en
porte bonheur sur les cadeaux qu'on
donne ah oui mais ça n'a pas beaucoup de
cadeaux un risque si match ne commence
un tel sabatier voilà c'est comme dans
bonux le premier cadeau ce la blancheur
des dents mais un site à taille on va
faire une première pause musicale alors
c'est quoi je sais que tu as sorti un 45
tours on montrera tout à l'heure la face
à ces le kitchen on le sait la face b
comment ça s'appelle
c'est une chanson que j'ai composée
moi-même pendant sept ans la musique a
fait un effort désespéré pour se mettre
au niveau et satin j'aimerais bien que
quelqu'un
voilà je chante entre les mac il jeûne
est interne à me dire en les coûts tout
de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces salles qui l'écoutent
[Musique]
ghoga
qin gang
[Musique]
distingué comme ça sans moi la serbie
non c'est comme un mariage avec moi-même
a manoeuvré par les pillages
[Musique]
que payet
le pitch
jo
ça tue
arrêtez tourne autour de moi c'est bien
pendue
h ier comme un épisode couchepin
[Musique]
jacqueline journée
je suis
[Musique]
tu joues s
voilà alors il ya une petite inversion
c'était kitching ça te gêne pas ta
taille et ils se sont carrément couru le
kitchen c'est une nouvelle danse que tu
as voulu 10 ont lancé comme une mode
on espère qu'on sera très nombreux à la
dansé comme ça commence ouais je
rappelle à nos amis téléspectateurs qui
peuvent bien sûr poser des questions
comme ils ont l'habitude de le faire
chaque vendredi à tain sur le micro 26
82 20 00 et à taez se fera un plaisir
puisqu'il se prépare au jeu de la vérité
à répondre à toutes les questions
on va déjà prendre une question avec nos
amis téléspectateurs qui sont avec nous
en direct un studio ce soir à commencer
par romuald que jack film elle sait que
tu voudras bien faire oui 73 non sur
quatre coins quelque chose comme ça les
cowboys et les indiens et cow boy à côté
de romuald une jeune fille qui va poser
une question après avoir dit son prénom
parce qu'on ne sait pas s'il vit sylvie
est ce que vous aimez bien jean-luc
lahaye c'est à dire que jean luc lahaye
c'est un peu chanté ici c'est le fils
qui chante un concours et puis karim à
côté qui va poser une question également
je m'appelle carrément ah ouais ça lui
karim c'est une question
qu'at-elle bien jean jacques goldman
ils s'insultent un château oui j'écoute
souvent des disques de jean jacques
goldman
oui mais tout le temps d'un disque de
gens comme j'aimerais bien
les voir un pari mais c'était bourré
comme tu trouves toujours pas pu voir au
petit matin les gens merci il ya
beaucoup de questions ici un studio
également par téléphone 26 82 20 00 tout
de suite un appel
allô allô en soir et bonjour je serais
pour savoir en même temps qu'il faudrait
pour faire une marionnette et en quoi
t'es fait pourtant bataillé et ce fait
il est construit en renard argenté et
puis c'est un peu un phénomène spéciale
lorsque ta taille a été construit en une
nuit pratiquement il a été on m'avait
donné un vieux manteau au renard et je
les construis à partir de là deux yeux
manteau en une seule nuit et il faut
dire aussi que ta taille d'un exemplaire
unique qui n'existent qui n'existe pas à
part le phénomène que vous voyez là
et puis alors ce ce personnage là est
pratiquement impossible à refaire je ne
suis jamais ni moi ni personne
d'ailleurs arrivé à reconstruire un
personnage avec le même regard et l'âme
la même vie que celui là bas je vous dis
je les fais en une nuit celui là mais je
me suis essayé après pendant des années
pour leur faire et puis jamais plus je
ne suis arrivé à le refaire voilà merci
beaucoup monsieur pour cette question
peut être d'autres appels aux 26 82 20
00 pour ta taille et entend l'état leur
de goldman de la et toi tu as fait les
premières parties de patrick sébastien
hervé vilard d'autres artistes serge la
main tu les connais bien tollé les
vedettes du show-business
oui j'attends entend discuter avec eux
oui ouais comment il se trouve sympa oui
et comment tu les trouves tu vois tout
de suite un appel 26 82 20 00 bonjour
c'est le moment cela n'est très bien
tard mais si oui de th non simple qu'est
ce que tu as dit chantal temps droit
social merci beaucoup madame c'est
gentil courageuse
oui c'est sûr plein gré déjà petit
vachement sympa je t'embrasse très très
fort merci à bâle photos des bic a fait
d'accord tu le seras ton adresse et puis
un instinct envers une grande
d'accord d'accord notre merci au revoir
et merci beaucoup
madame pourrait parfois la question mais
c'était qu'elle te met beaucoup en tout
cas la main quinze petits-enfants
alors la belle famille a bien travaillé
tout de suite on va écouter une deuxième
chanson alors ce coup ci j'espère que
c'est bien la face b
il vaut mieux un bon sur la face à comme
ces phrases sont la face d'accord
annoncé le kin shing petite taille et à
y aller micro
mais chanter sur 100 qui me tient à quel
prix
écoutez
[Musique]
je veux dire que quelqu'un vient me
chercher je me dis que tu que non mais
d'ailleurs je veuille bien que quelqu'un
l'emmène loin d'ici
[Musique]
n'importe où louis un goy avoue ados à
buenos aires
j'ai cherché à mieux que moi tu veux
dire sao paulo salle apollon
oui
[Musique]
du sucre sanguin
j'aimerais que tu vois partir d'égalité
aucun pays
je me dis ce que je trouvais à payer
à transpole et oui à l'époque qui
devient seul autre mois plus grand que
moi même on y est 80 points sont innées
[Musique]
gentil il y met
je vais bien que quelques années
ce qui me tue et fashion aussi
si tout ça
bien à tour eiffel tu dois à mon team
voilà la tour eiffel en toi y 13
qui te
peter toi
j'ai les doigts dans la manche chasse
est vachement marc laporte tablettes
[Musique]
c
oh
encore au vote qu'est ce que ces jours
un lit je joue
[Musique]
jamais
tiens à bouger
[Musique]
à
les gars
la concurrence
ça
j'aimerais bien te amo six mois c'est le
parlement
la mesure
j'étais la toile non non
j'aimerais
et
moi j'aimerais bien qu'un
kim est au repos
[Musique]
pour moi tout seul
jésus ce qui manque dans le
dans le
là
j'aimerais
quelqu'un a mûri
non
étant aussi une vente avec beaucoup de
couleurs oui on s'est un moment qui peut
acheter
oui pour l'insulter un metteur en scène
julie chenette aussi chat chien
qu'est ce que tu chantes pas très house
et la saison il peut chanter un morceau
avec moi depuis longtemps et de troncs
méchante avec nous ben pourquoi l aller
on l'attend encore tomber tous les deux
un semblant d'accord voilà les tatamis
tu pourrais faire présentateur parce que
je lui pose pas mal de questions doit
aussi oui tu me manques je le micro mon
avis ils veulent couper
je vais leur prendre on a tout juste le
temps de reprendre peut-être une
question ou 2 au 26 82 20 00 voilà à
l'eau non oui bonsoir une question très
vite ce rapide bonjour radio 1 bonjour
femmes you baby paix rhdp bien c'est
super je parie qu'on va pas voir le
temps posé la question parce que quentin
seconde la question vite les petits gars
moi j'ai dix ans c'est tout voilà je te
dirais la prochaine fois parce que je
sais pas encore voilà merci beaucoup
fabio et merci pour toutes ces questions
merci à notre quiz est trop court on n'y
peut rien merci à tous nos jeunes amis
qui sont venus
gentiment nous rejoindre en direct un
plateau aujourd'hui tu connais yannick
penagos brown et où il nous présente un
jeu qui s'appelle avec ou sans bagage
qu'on va tous de se découvrir
et puis à une prochaine fois au revoir
[Musique]